Oh
I think a lot about the psychology of
spaces right the intention of
architecture the capacity to design
dwellings that inform our inner world
walk into a room and you start feeling
better and you don't quite know why they
realize the light it shapes the minds
the shadows everything about how we've
installed impregnated mind and intention
and agency into the physical form shows
us the ways in which architecture in
which design is really about the design
of inner space that's right you design
be without to design the within this is
a wonderful idea I think architects
don't get celebrated enough in our
society because these are the people
that allow us to design cities spaces
and dwellings in which we unfold right
and if anything architects should work
together with psychologists and with
designers who understand the impact of
shapes shadows and forms upon human
subjectivity right design matters
architecture matter
Oh